Hé pardonnez-moi monsieur je vous remercie si la
mauvaise voiture
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici qu'est-ce qui se
passe j'ai été envoyé pour vous chercher pour une
raison
ah il y a une fleur sur les oreillers une
fleur dans la salle de bain comme si nous étions
importants le seul  la chance que nous avons est si nous devenons
tous les trois fous de ce gars qui
est peut-être qu'elle peut nous aider ne t'inquiète pas
il n'a pas le droit de le toucher il
sait pourquoi tu es là écoute moi
je m'appelle Hedwig quel âge as tu  9 Je n'ai
jamais vu un cas comme celui-ci avant
23 identités vivent dans le corps de Kevin qui
êtes-
vous m'aidez
à sortir de votre tête Regan vous essayez de
me tromper je dirai que
vous n'êtes pas le plus intelligent un individu
avec plusieurs  les personnalités peuvent changer
la chimie de leur corps avec leurs pensées
quelqu'un vient pour vous qui vient
la Bête il y a un homme ici il
nous a enlevé et il va me tuer
nous sommes destinés à quelque chose quelque chose d'
horrible le monde comprendra maintenant
la Bête est réelle il est devenu horrible  remercier
les gens et il fera un travail horrible  merci à
vous